دعت بعثه الامم المتحده لحقوق الانسان في
اوكرانيا كافر الى التحقيق في فيديو نشر
مؤخرا يظهر او يظهر فيه اعدام لاسرى روسيا
واعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه مؤخرا ان
قواتك اعدمت اكثر من 10 اسرع حرب من
الجنود الروسي في جريمه صورها جنود
اوكرانيين ونشروها دون اخفاء وجوههم وفقا
للدفاع الروسيه التي شددت على ان الفيديو
والمنشور لهذه المذبح الجماعيه بحق الاسرى
الروس العزل يؤكد طبيعتكاف طبيعه النظام
الوحشي بقياده زنسكي حسب قولهم وهم من
يدافعون همم عنه ويدعمون وفق الوصف الروسي
بدورها نفذ السلطات الاوكرانيه تنفيذ
احكام اعدام بحق الاسره من القوات الروسيه
في ظل الحرب القائمه بين البلدتين
صواريخ روسيه قيمتها تتجاوز مليار يورو
عادت بنتائج مخيبه لي موسكو لتقتصر على
انقطاع التيار الكهربائي لساعه قليله
والسبب الابداع الاوكراني رفقا لتقرير
لصحيفه بوليتكو الامريكيه التطورات
الحاصله في الميدان علمت الاوكرانيين
كيفيه التخلص من العقليه السوفياتيه
المنهكه التي تصعب ايجاد الحلول وقتها
الحرب فما تواصل سلسله الهجمات الروسيه
المتكرره على مشاهد الطاقه في اوكرانيا
كان الابداع والارتجال وسيد الموقف في
تجاوز ازمه انقطاع الكهرباء حيث يقوم
المهندسون الاوكرانيون باصلاح الوضع في
غضون السعاده والسعاده الطاقه بعد ضربات
الصواريخ الروسيه اسقاط تصريحات لمسؤول
اوكراني نشرتها صحيفه بوليسيكو فان
اوكرانيا تتجه نحو خلق نظام طاقه يتماشى
مع فكره الصمود في وجه الهجوم الروسي
واعتماد استراتيجيه جديده قائمه على تنسيق
الجهودي هلالي دراسه السيناريوهات
المحتمله وايجاد حلول لها ضمن مخططات
اعاده التوحشيح